yeah and it's crazy too because like did
you notice like uh
because i want to give you another and i
might be wrong giving you credit for
this
but i feel like the new pause is ao yeah
absolutely right absolutely saucy
santana the gay rapper yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i was talking to him about
whether or not paz was at home uh
homosexual pause um
homophobic yeah yeah and he was like nah
he's like me and my homies do the same
thing but we'd be like hey yo yeah yeah
everybody that's your thing
it kind of
it's like a new york thing but i'm like
you made it pop at least yes but see
everybody a lot of people in new york
say i'm not going to take credit for
creating it
but i feel like
you know um humbly that it did
start taking over the like you know
instead of pauses ao now because of the
viral video yeah and um but before that
i always was saying and the people
around me from like say philly or other
places would just start saying it as
well when they after they be around me
you know what i'm saying and like yeah
you know they didn't understand that was
like poor so they just started saying it
on regular [ __ ] like oh i spilled my
shade yo i'm so yeah oh no you don't do
it like that you know what i'm saying